[Music]
4.6 billion years ago our Sun ignites a
cloud of dust and gas circles the infant
star then gravity gets to work sucking
in gas dust ice and rocks to form the
infant planets the planets formed out of
building blocks smaller chunks of
material rock ice
stuff that came together over time
the frenzy of swirling colliding matter
leaves behind debris as rocky rubble and
the asteroid belt and ice and the Kuiper
belt then Neptune and Uranus got in on
the act
scattering the debris out further most
of them got threatening the solar system
forever but the ones that didn't go on
these big long million year looping
orbits and that's the work Club billions
of icy rocks were thrown out in all
directions until a ball of debris formed
around the whole solar system
the Oort cloud comets are dynastar bones
of solar system formation contained in
them are the ingredients that went up to
make our planets most of the Oort cloud
objects will stay in this icy cloud
forever orbiting the distant Sun but a
few get nudged loose and the Sun's
gravity pulls them inwards like moths to
a flame is such a common could sneak up
on you you won't even know is there
these comments can be many miles across
and they're moving extremely rapidly
sometimes as much as a hundred miles per
second this makes them pretty dangerous
how dangerous ask a dinosaur
some people think that the massive
impact that killed off the dinosaurs may
have been caused by a huge port cloud
comet
they can be every bit as dangerous as
the asteroids usually blamed for
extinctions on earth we'd have little or
no warning because we have no idea what
is hurling stuff out of the Oort cloud
at us
you